High by 71-year-old husband had two stairs put in his heart today,
aspirin 81 milligrams, and another medication.
However, this makes him have bruises and bleed easily,
especially after shower-rated, even before taking any blood thinners.
He seemed to easily bruise and bleed.
One concern also is that in the past he has had
high H. Pylori levels in ulcers.
And as it is in his digestion, as his digestion is a bit delicate,
so would there be any advice on how to counteract any possible
internal bleeding or ill effects of bleeding elsewhere?
Well, you have to follow the prescribed doctor's recommendations
as far as that medication. I can't legally tell you to do anything
differently with the medication, but the doctor should be able to run some tests
to see what his need is for that and how long he needs to be
on that, and he should be addressing these other
comorbidities. Now, you cannot be taking things
also supplement-wise that are also blood thinners,
so be careful of that. And unfortunately, one of
a good supplement to help kill H. Pylori in garlic,
and garlic is probably the number one supplemental
blood thinner, so you cannot be taking garlic if you're taking
blood thinners and you're already having bleeding issues.
As far as trying to heal a bleeding ulcer,
that's totally different. You shouldn't really be trying to kill
H. Pylori with, like I said, anything that's going to
be in blood. Burmary does another great killer of
H. Pylori, but one thing to help heal a bleeding ulcer can be
well, there's different products out there. We have a product called
Clear GI. It's got slippery elm. It's got
a lot of different herbs, okra, and
glutamine to help heal the gut. So, there's a lot of good
gut healing products out there, as long as he doesn't have
cancer, he can definitely go on a product like that.
So, you do want to help heal any bleeding ulcer.
You do want to also look for discolouration of any stools,
because that will be a side of bleeding, an internal bleed,
and your doctor should be informed that doctor who has prescribed
this should be informed exactly all of the
morbidity so that they can properly manage the medication.